All righty.
So we've been talking about,
the last time we talked about the
different ways that this
extraordinary process called
evolution has resulted in different
ways that organisms exploit the
carbon and energy sources that are
available on earth.
And as we talked about that we find
that whatever is thermodynamically
possible in terms of redox gradients
in the environment you will find an
organism that has evolved to exploit
it.  And one thing I haven't
mentioned to you guys yet --
Maybe I've mentioned it but I
haven't driven it home is that in
the microbial world right now 99.
% of the microbes that life on earth
have never been cultivated.
So it's a vastly unknown universe,
the details.  So the metabolic
pathways that I'm describing here
are just the tip of the iceberg in
terms of what's possible.
So last time we were talking at the
biochemical scale.
This time we're now going to scale
up and think of these biochemical
processes on a global level.
And we're going to talk about
primary productivity which is really
just another word for the collective
photosynthesis of all of the
photosynthesizers on earth.
So who are the dominant primary
producers?  Well,
we've already talked about this.
And just to get ourselves oriented
let's think of in water the primary
photosynthetic organisms,
the primary producers are
phytoplankton.
And let's just look at one
phytoplankton cell,
OK?  This is a single cell so this
would be maybe ten microns in size.
And inside that cell we have a
chloroplast, and you've learned all
this in other lectures and including
my lectures, which takes up CO2 and
evolves oxygen and makes sugars
which go to, what's the organelle
where respiration takes place?
Mitochondria.  Which goes to the
mitochondrion and is respired.
CO2 is evolved and oxygen is taken
up.  So this little single cell gets
through life through photosynthesis
primarily, but it also takes the
products of photosynthesis and burns
them inside the cell.
So this is what we call respiration.
And it's important to remember that
even photosynthetic organisms
respire, OK?  But then there's this
whole other group of organisms that
last time we called heterotrophs
that can only respire.
They rely on the photosynthetic
product from photosynthetic
organisms.  So that's in water.
And then on land the main primary
producers, productivity are plants.
And we'll just symbolize these as a
tree.  And we all know that the tree
takes up CO2, evolves oxygen.
If you blow this up, you just take
a leaf, OK?  That's a blowup.
And then you blowup again and take
a cell from the leaf.
This cell is identical in function
to the single microscopic
phytoplankton cell, OK?
So the process in both of these
ecosystems, this could be grass,
it could be moss, it could be
anything else,
the process is the same in terms of
what's involved in productivity.
OK.  Now, you have a handout for
this lecture that has a lot of the
definitions that I'm going to now
very briefly put on the board.
Oh, I should tell you also that in
the last ten minutes of the lecture
I'm going to show you another
incredible clip from the Blue Planet
series that I showed you last time
so you have something to look
forward to.  So let's
define some terms.
Biomass we're going to call B.
And as I said this is all in the
handout.
So I'm just going to give you the
short version here.
And the units of this can be of
course anything,
but normally it's something like
grams carbon per meter squared.
And what does that mean?  Well,
it means if you have, in a
terrestrial ecosystem,
OK, where you have trees,
it would mean that you would
calculate the biomass.
You'd take a square meter and you'd
integrate up and collect all of the
biomass in that surface area,
OK?  So that's what that means.
So grams carbon in that square
meter.  For an aquatic ecosystem
it's the opposite.
You take a square meter of the
surface water,
let's put some waves on here,
and you integrate all the way down.
How far?  When will you not have
anymore primary,
oh, no, biomass?  When will you no
longer have any more photosynthetic
biomass in the oceans or in a lake?
Pycnocline.  Oh,
that's a good answer.
Not necessarily, though.
But it often corresponds to that.
The pycnocline is a density gradient
in aquatic ecosystems.
But what is absolutely essential
for photosynthesis?
Light.  Light.  So you go down
until there's no light.
Absolutely.  There won't be any
photosynthesis where there's no
light.  This is the one thing we
know for sure,
OK?  And that's usually in the
oceans around 200 meters.
And in lakes it depends on how rich
they are.  In the Charles River it's
about one meter because
it's such a mess.
In fact, well,
I shouldn't say a mess,
but it's very productive.
In fact, legend has it, and I don't
know if this is true,
that it's actually safe to swim in
the Charles in terms of the water
quality, but the reason you're not
supposed to swim is because the
visibility is so bad that if
anything happened they'd never find
you.  But I don't know if that is
true.  That could be
an urban legend.
OK, so we're going to define gross
primary productivity.
GPP, gross primary productivity is
the rate of photosynthesis --
-- and grams carbon per meter
squared per year.
And of course the units here are not,
the absolute units,
this could be per day and this could
be per square millimeter if you
wanted, but the units are amount per
unit area per unit time,
OK?  And then we're going to define
the respiration rate,
the respiration of the autotrophs.
So this would be the respiration
rate of the photosynthetic organisms,
which is why we call them R sub A.
And that's going to have the same
units, OK?  So it's grams carbon per
meter squared per unit respired.
And net primary productivity is
then gross primary productivity
minus, so net primary productivity
of an ecosystem is the amount of
carbon, CO2 that's drawn into the
system through photosynthesis minus
the amount that was respired by the
plants, by the organisms that did
the photosynthesis.
In a sense, you can think of it as
the amount of carbon that actually
goes into a plant growing,
OK, that goes into the biomass of a
tree or that goes into the division
of a single celled phytoplankton
into two phytoplankton.
And then a lot of that is lost
through respiration.  OK.
We can also define mean
resonance time --
-- as MRT, which is the biomass
divided by the net primary
productivity.
So what are the units of the mean
resonance time?  It should
be obvious but --
Years, right, or time.
Mean resonance time is time.
And that's really, if you want to
think about it,
if you think of yourself as a carbon
atom that's drawn into a tree
through photosynthesis,
it's the average amount of time you
will spend, your one
atom in that tree.
OK?  It's the average resonance,
the mean resonance time.  Well,
actually, that's wrong,
right?  It's not the amount of time
that you, that one atom will spend,
but it's on average the amount of
time that atoms will spend in the
tree.  OK.  And then the
fractional turnover --
-- is equal to one over the mean
resonance time.
And it has the units of obviously
years to the minus one.
And it's the fraction, if you think
of a tree again,
it's the fraction of the carbon in
that tree that is renewed by new
carbon every year.
Now, these two concepts will become
very important again when we start
to talk about global biogeochemical
cycles.
And we'll talk about the resonance
time, the various elements in
various components in the earth
system.  OK.  So now let's go on and
look at, first of all,
I should have shown this slide last
time.  I'm trying to not walk around
too much because this fellow is
filming me or filming
these classes.
But we should briefly take a look at
the absorption spectrum of all of
the plants in the biosphere.
Could we turn the lights down a
little?  Or I guess I'm
in charge of that.
There.  A little bit better maybe.
This is the absorption spectrum of
the pigment chlorophyll,
chlorophyll A that is the pigment
that all green plants have and they
use to absorb sunlight.
And you'll notice that over the
course of evolution all of these
white bands are accessory pigments.
That different organisms have
evolved to also capture light.
And they pass on that energy to the
chlorophyll molecule.
And the point is that if you look
across all of the visible light and
even beyond there are pigments that
have evolved to capture that solar
energy collectively in the ecosystem.
OK, so let's look at,
now we're going to look at world net
primary productivity.
So essentially photosynthesis on a
global scale.  And I'm going to tell
you right up front.
These numbers are extremely
approximated.  And I've taken these
numbers from various textbooks.
Your textbook doesn't even have a
table like this in it.
In fact, your textbook is very weak
in this section of biology.
But there are always tradeoffs in
choosing textbooks.
So I've taken this from textbooks
and I've rounded off these numbers.
And so I just want you to go
through and understand the structure
of the table.
The idea is not to memorize
particular numbers but understand
and have a feeling for the relative
amounts of productivity in different
ecosystems.  So,
first of all, here's our units of
grams per year,
world net primary productivity.
These are grams of carbon, OK?  And
if we first look at the total amount
on land, in this particular table is
177 versus the marine total is 54.
But the new estimates,
I've taken this out of sort of more
primarily literature than textbooks,
really show these numbers to be more
like this.  That shows you how
variable this is.
It changes every decade.
Showing that the amount of
photosynthesis in the oceans is
roughly on par with the amount on
land.  And to remind you of our
units here, weight-wise this is 50
to 70 billion Volkswagen's
worth of carbon.
I mean that's a lot of carbon every
year that is going into these
ecosystems.  OK,
so let's look and dissect the table
a little bit.  Looking at tropical
forests like the rainforest in the
Amazon that are some of the most
productive ecosystems in the world.
You can see that over here their net
primary productivity per meter
squared is 2,000.
And then you look down here at the
open ocean which on a per meter
squared basis,
a very unproductive ecosystem,
there are tiny little phytoplankton,
is 100.  But looking further, before
I get to the but which
is the punch line.
That's the trouble with animation.
The biomass in the tropical forest
is enormous, obviously trees,
whereas the biomass in the open
ocean is very tiny.
But if we look at the percent of
the surface of the earth that is
covered by these two different
ecosystems the open ocean is huge
compared to the tropical forest.
So on a global scale, because of
the aerial coverage here these two
ecosystems contribute equally, OK?
So it's a combination of net primary
productivity and the coverage of the
global ocean.  OK.
Let's go back to that for a minute.
So let's --
-- talk about turnover times or mean
resonance times.
Just eyeballing it,
can you give me an estimate in terms
of days, months,
years, decades, centuries,
order of magnitude for the mean
resonance time of carbon in all the
phytoplankton in a
marine ecosystem?
Is it days, months, years,
centuries, decades?
Well, don't guess.
Well, you can guess but minutes is
wrong.  So having guessed minutes is
wrong now you use your analytical
brain and you look at this,
mean resonance time, which is
biomass divided by net primary
productivity.  Here's the biomass.
Round that off.
And here's the net primary
productivity.
And the units here is years.
Like a month did I hear?  I didn't
hear.  Right.  It's about one-tenth
of year which is about a month.
About a month.
Does everybody follow that?
It's just to round this off,
five over 50 is 0.1, biomass over
MPP.  How about for the terrestrial
ecosystem, what's the average amount
of time a carbon atom spends
in the average tree?
Years, right?  Decades.
Many years.  Maybe decades to
centuries.  This is a way we think
about these things.
We don't have an exact number.
But you want to get an order of
magnitude feeling.
So carbon is turning over very,
very fast in the marine ecosystem
but very slowly in the terrestrial
ecosystem.  And the simple way to
think about that is that
phytoplankton don't have trunks,
but there's a more complicated way
to think about it.
OK, so now, all of this primary
productivity that we've made,
all of this photosynthesis, as we
talked about, is the base of the
food webs in all ecosystems.
And so we're going to start to
dissect this.  This is a marine food
web showing phytoplankton that are
eaten by zooplankton.
We used to talk about food chains,
but we well now that it's not a
chain.  It's really a very complex
web and very hard to put organisms
and assign them to particular
sections.  Phytoplankton are eaten
by zooplankton.
Zooplankton are eaten by worms.
You've got blue crabs, barnacles,
and the top predators shore birds
and sea bass.  Now,
an important part of these food webs
is also all of the carbon,
the primary productivity that is not
eaten while it's alive.
So some things just die,
right?  You have dead carbon lying
around.  And that dead carbon falls
into what's called a different food
web, the detritus food web.
And we're going to talk about that.
And it comes from all of these
different components in the food web.
So now we're going to more
analytically look at the flow of
carbon.  And when we talk about
carbon we are also talking about
energy, right?
Carbon and energy are the same
thing.  I mean they're
interconvertable.
So we're going to look at the flow
of carbon from the phytoplankton to
the zooplankton through that trophic
level.  And to do this we have to
talk about some definitions.
And again this is in your handout
so I'm not going to write all this
on the board but we'll just walk
through this.  The flow of carbon or
energy through a trophic level,
which is one of these links, OK?
This is one trophic level.
This is the next trophic level.
Or you can also think of this as an
organism.  This type of analysis
applies to both.
And we start out with the
productivity at trophic level and
minus one, OK?
And so the first would be primary
productivity coming into the system.
Some of that productivity, some of
that carbon is not ingested by the
next trophic level.
That's lost as dead organic matter,
detritus, whatever we want to call
it.  So that's D sub n the portion
not consumed.  Then some of it is
ingested by the organism,
I sub n.  And then some fraction of
that is assimilated by the organism.
That means it's taken into its
biochemistry and goes toward
building biomass.
And some of it is lost as fecal
matter produced,
that's F sub n.  And urine would
also be a part of this,
waste products.  And then some of it
is then, the rest of it is then
available, oh,
some of it, this is important,
is lost as respiration.  And then
the rest is available as
productivity for the next
trophic level.  OK.
So different types of organisms.
First, before we get to that, using
this analysis we can start to define
efficiencies of energy conversion
through this system.
And this is because different types
of organisms assimilate carbon with
different efficiencies.
And that is important in the flow
of carbon through different
types of ecosystems.
So let's look at the first
efficiency that would be I,
ingested, reflecting the amount
that's ingested relative to the
amount that's available.
And this is called the exploitation
efficiency, OK?
I sub n divided by P sub n minus
one.  The next one similarly would
be A sub n, the amount that's
assimilated relative to the amount
that's ingested.
And that is the assimilation
efficiency.  And finally the amount
that goes to the next trophic level
divided by the amount that's
assimilated, which is the production
efficiency, the amount that actually
goes to productivity that is
assimilated.  And these all
multiplied together give you the
ecological efficiency.
And that is sometimes called the
trophic transfer efficiency.
That's the amount of carbon that is
basically lost as you go through one
trophic level.
And usually, and we'll talk about
this in a minute,
this is 10% to 20% actually makes it
through the system,
and the rest is lost to respiration
or detritus or fecal matter.
OK, so let's talk about now how
different organisms vary in terms of
efficiencies.
We have, in terms of the
exploitation efficiency,
if you're talking about, for example,
tree insects.
So insects feeding on trees is about
1% to 10%.  They don't take that
much of the tree.
If it's grass to animals it's more
like 20%.  And if it's phytoplankton
to zooplankton it's more
like 20% to 40%.
In other words,
zooplankton harvests much of the
primary productivity,
no, almost half of the productivity
that the phytoplankton have made.
OK.  What about assimilation
efficiency?  How does this vary
between organisms?
Well, this one, you can think about
it as if you eat food that is,
I was going to say not you, but it
is true, we are all animals so it
applies to us, too.
If you eat food that is similar in
composition to your own bodily
composition you're more efficient at
assimilating it because you don't
have to break it down as much and
reorganize it.
So herbivores,
organisms that eat plant matter are
20% to 50% efficient in
their assimilation.
But carnivores is more like 80%.
Because you are meat and if you eat
meat you don't have as much waste
than if you eat a lot of fiber.
So there are big differences there.
And then in terms of, that is not a
value judgment on whether you should
eat meat or not.
I just want to make that very clear.
What?  OK.  But later on we'll talk
about the difference between eating
meat globally and being vegetarians
in terms of utilizing primary
productivity on the earth.
But in terms of production
efficiency you have warm-blooded
organisms having a 2% production
efficiency.
Whereas cold-blooded have a 40%
production efficiency.
Why would that be?
Yes.  If you're warm-blooded,
does anybody know the technical term
for that?  It is if you
are homeotherm.
Or what did you say?
Endothermic.  I'm not sure.
I think that's chemistry.  It
sounded good, though.
So there are homeotherms and
heterotherms.  It doesn't matter.
The point is that these have to
maintain their body temperature like
we do.  That takes a lot of energy.
Whereas, these go with the flow so
to speak, that technical term.
But that doesn't take as much energy.
If it's cold they just let their
body get cold.
They don't burn,
burn, burn to keep the temperature
constant.  OK,
so that's how organisms differ.
Now let's move on to the next
chapter in which now we are
going to look at --
We were looking at the flow through
one trophic level.
Now we're going to connect a whole
bunch of trophic levels.
We're going to look at the flow of
energy through this component of
this food web and do a more thorough
analysis.  OK,
so this gets kind of messy but let's
start here.  I better use the
powerful one.  OK,
so each one of these is what we call
a trophic level.
And these are the primary producers,
the photosynthetic organisms.  Here
is our gross primary production
absorbing sunlight.
Some of that is lost to heat.
Some of that is lost to respiration.
Here is our little R sub A,
remember?  Right here.  And some of
it, the net primary productivity is
available for ingestion at the next
trophic level which are
the herbivores.
So all we're doing here is ganging
up a whole bunch of those individual
analyses.  And then the next trophic
levels are the carnivores and then
the second carnivores.
And the number of links you have
here is something that is obviously
determined by the efficiency of
transfer from one to another and the
total amount of energy that comes
into the system.
So here in our ecosystem we have
carbon being lost at each
step to detritus.
And you have feces at each link.
This all goes down and becomes part
of the detritus food web.
And in that you have two forms of
carbon.  You have particulate
organic carbon which is pieces of
dead carbon floating around,
dead leaves, dead phytoplankton,
whatever.  And then you also have
dissolved organic carbon.
When these plants die and the
phytoplankton die they burst open.
And the glucose and amino acids and
all of that dissolve into the water
in the system.
And that becomes dissolved organic
carbon which is available for this
microbial food web,
an entirely different food web
that's coupled to the system.
So you have the detritivore.  This
the grazing food web here.
The waste from that goes to the
detritivores and the microbes.
And then whatever is left over
after that is called refractory
carbon.
That means none of the creatures are
able to break it open and really get
energy out of it.
And in the big picture what is this?
We talked about it actually last
time.  Fossil fuel,
exactly.  This is the carbon that
actually accumulates over time that
when ecosystems are finished
processing all of the
primary production.
OK, so I'm trying to time this right
so that we make sure we have time
for the movie.
So let's look at a couple of ways
we can think about this.
Let's just compare.
If we look at the open ocean
ecosystem versus the
tropical forest.
And the average,
oh, I forgot one thing.
OK.  If we take now the gross
primary productivity.
And I'm going to circle all of the
respirations.  See the purple here?
So this is all the carbon that's
being fixed.  This is that is lost
to respiration.
And we can define a new parameter
which is net ecosystem production.
And that is gross primary
production minus the respiration of
all of the autotrophies,
R sub A, minus the respiration of
all of the heterotrophic components
of the system.
So that would be the herbivores,
carnivores, detritivores,
microorganisms.
That's all the carbon that's
respired and lost to CO2.
So you can add this to this.
So we'd have net ecosystem
production.  Production equals GPP
minus RA minus the sum of all the
heterotrophs.  Now,
in very mature ecosystems this net
ecosystem production is essentially
nothing.  All right?
Everything that's produced is
consumed.
For example, in a tropical
rainforest you don't have a huge
buildup of organic carbon in a
tropical rainforest.
Everything that's produced is
basically consumed and this is zero.
But in a young forest, say a
plantation at the extreme where you
plant trees and they're increasing
in biomass, then obviously this net
ecosystem production is a positive
number.  What if net ecosystem
production is a negative number?
It won't be there for long,
right?  You've got to have things
photosynthesizing net at least
enough to maintain the ecosystem.
I mean you can have it for a
transient for not any steady state.
OK.  All right.  Talking about
ecological efficiencies again.
If we talk about the average --
The average ecological efficiency of
the open ocean is about 25% and of
the tropical rain forest is about 5%.
So the average number of trophic
levels, that's basically the number
of links in the food web in these
two systems is about 7.1 and 3.2.
In other words,
when you have more efficiency of
transfer from one link to another
you can have more links obviously.
So getting back to humans again,
and this gets back to in terms of
what we might think about as a
global human society.
If you go from wheat to man you lose
90% of the energy in that transfer.
If you go from wheat to cows to man
you lose 90% here and
you lose 90% here.
So obviously in terms of feeding the
world it's much better to go
directly from wheat to humans than
to go from wheat to cows to humans.
You all know this but it's
important to remember that.
And unfortunately the trend in the
world is to go more from here to
here instead of the
other way around.
Just something to remember in terms
of the application of this knowledge.
OK.  Finally very quickly I'm going
to skip over this and go to another
way to look at what we've been
talking about.
It's just another diagram of the
same thing.  You have the
photosynthetic organisms that the
entire world depends on,
this productivity for food and fiber.
And that most of that is lost
through respiration and the rest
goes to the other organisms
including detritivores.
So a big question is how much of
this global primary productivity,
this global photosynthesis have
humans taken over?
It's really hard to answer that
question, OK, but a lot of
ecologists have been working very
hard at understanding the fraction
of global photosynthesis that has
been what's called co-opted
by humans.
And the estimates range from 10% to
55%.  The amount that we use
directly as food or fuel or fiber or
timber is not that great,
but there's a lot of productivity
that's diverted as crop waste,
burning, et cetera.  And land
conversion obviously uses up a lot
of habitat and productivity.
So the significant point here is
that as we co-opt this primary
productivity we change dramatically
all of the food webs that rely on it,
and that is what is part of the path
to extinction of a lot of species.
And the big question is how much
can we co-opt?
I mean we're on the road to taking
over the primary productivity of the
earth, there's no question,
completely.  Unless we set up
reserves that's it, that's
where we're marching.
Now, when we're in charge of it,
is it going to function the way we
need it to function to maintain our
atmosphere and to provide us with
the food and fiber that we need?
That's still an open question.  OK,
so now I'm going to show you this
really neat DVD because these
pictures of food webs are deadly
dull and don't represent anything at
all of what the reality is like.
So I'm going to show you three
weeks in the life of
a real food web.
And I want you to think about two
things when you're watching it.
Don't just think you're at home in
front of your TV watching a nature
show and going brain dead or
something.  Think about what you've
learned in this class.
So think about the gigatons of
carbon that are flowing through this
system.  More importantly this
entire food web and everything
that's going on in it is
orchestrated by the information in
the genes of the organisms
in the food web.
That's the information content that
structures this whole thing.
And how it's all orchestrated and
coordinated and happens the same way
more or less every year is
absolutely mind blowing as far as
I'm concern and a major,
major challenge for ecology and for
molecular ecology.  OK.